les braconniers cela existe encore chez
nous et pour cause après enquête des
agents de l'office national de la chasse
trois personnes ont été interpellées par
la police de tours ils étaient 1 elle
était impliquée dans un trafic de
chardonneret élégant des petits oiseaux
très convoité une espèce son déclin en
france moitié d'entre eux ont disparu
le mode opératoire des braconniers il
mettait de la glu sur les branches
d'arbres pour les capturer en bord de
chair de nombreuses pages ont été
retrouvés au domicile de ces braconniers
au domicile de ces braconniers deux
d'entre eux comparaîtront devant la
justice il encourt un an de prison et
15000 euros d'amande